superheroes stick together in the
aftermath of Sony and Disney failing to
come to an agreement to renegotiate
terms of his deal that allowed Tom
Hollands spider-man to be a part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
Deadpool actor Ryan Reynolds came
forward to address the situation my nose
responds to spider-man swinging out of
the MCU was witty as all get-out which
is to be expected when dealing with the
actor whose tongue is firmly planted in
his cheek but it's sadly offered fans
little comfort in this tumultuous time
twitter user chaotic King was one of
many fans who turn to Rennels to help
save spider-man or at least give them a
bit of Solace after having their Spidey
loving hearts shattered clearly hoping
for a silver lining in all the darkness
chaotic King asked Reynolds on Twitter
whether spider-man's MCU exit could
eventually result in a team of movie
with spider-man and Deadpool Reynolds
gave a half humorous half heartbreaking
response you can but you can only see it
in my hearts if fans weren't
sufficiently devastated over the news a
Holland's web-slinging vigilante won't
be able to play on the Marvel Studios
playground anymore
Reynolds tweet absolutely crushed them
one fan tweeted at Reynolds
that's literally not the response we
wanted we wanted a yes a big fat yes
please and thank you
another fan begged the actor Ryan please
help us
clearly sorrowful spider-man fans are
placing a lot of stock in Reynolds
ability to either roll up his sleeves
and check it out with Sony executives
himself or do some sorts of behind the
scenes string pulling to get spider-man
back into Marvel's movie realm yeah it's
me Deadpool for that you can't refuse as
much as we love Reynolds and as cool as
it would be to see his raunchy hard
r-rated superhero film series collide
with spider-man's world it's strange
that so many people are wanting him to
do something about the Sony Disney split
granted Deadpool is a Marvel Comics
character that Marvel Studios hasn't yet
been able to use in the MCU due to
rights restrictions which is a fate that
spider-man had suffered up until 2015
when Disney and Sony struck a deal to
let Hollins hero character appear in
Marvel movies while Sony retained
financial distribution and creative
control but there's a lot more at play
here and there's basically nothing that
Reynolds can do to change things more
Reynolds is one of a few actors who can
commiserate with Holland about playing a
Marvel character that isn't allowed in
the MCU there's a high probability that
Reynolds Deadpool actually will join the
MCU in the future after
Disney bought the majority of 20th
Century Fox's assets in a 71 point three
billion dollar deal earlier this year
the house of mouse acquired a bunch of
Marvel Comics characters who screen
rights resided at Fox Deadpool is one of
them and well nothing has been confirmed
by the way of a third Deadpool movie or
Wade Wilson's forthcoming inclusion in
the MCU it seems fairly inevitable the
Merc with a mouth made big money at the
box office and has helped revolutionize
the superhero genre sparking studio
executives to consider giving darker
grittier and more violent characters
their own franchises plainly puts Disney
and Marvel would be fools not to induct
a Deadpool into the MCU regardless what
that ends up happening and even if
Reynolds never slips back into the red
and black suit for another Deadpool
movie Deadpool is property of Marvel
Studios spider-man isn't and now that
Sony and Disney have done the corporate
equivalent of filing for divorce it's
virtually impossible for a Deadpool
spider-man team-up movie to happen
Reynolds may have a ton of clout in
Hollywood and in a much presence on
social media but one thing he doesn't
have is the power to squash the beef
between two of the biggest entertainment
companies in the world which as we might
said it wasn't so Peter Parker and Wade
Wilson probably won't ever meet like
Reynolds fans will simply have to keep
that dream alive in their hearts check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
answer the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]